لم يعد الحرم الجامعي في مصر حرما امنا
كما عاهده الطلاب واولياء الامور فاعلم
دار اشهر قليلا مضت ازداد ظاهره العنف ضد
فتيات الجامعات حقوقيون يرجعون تفاقم
الظاهره الى سوء استخدام وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
بدات تنتشر في الفتره الاخيره نتيجه
التوصيل التوثيق الخاطئ بمعنى ان هنا
ابتدى انتشرها على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ويمكن هي احنا هنا بنركز مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ودورها سواء السلبي او
الايجابي على هذه الجرائم فبالتالي ان
احنا هنا بالليل بيؤساء استخدام هذا
التوصيل
جمعيات دعم المراه والمؤسسات النسويه يقع
على عاتقها مسؤوليه هذه الجرائم لما تمثله
من عنصريه تناهض الفتاه على حساب الشاب
والسيد دعم المراه هي من اهم اسباب العنف
ضد المراه مش محتاجين مؤسسات تناصر المراه
اكثر من كده لكن محتاجين دعوات ان ترجع
المراه الى صحيح العادات اللي احنا
اتربينا عليها وان تكون ضيعه في يد الرجل
وبينما تكثر اسباب تلك الظاهره في مصر
وتنقسم ما بينعم او ناشر فان مختصون يرون
ان الاسره والتنشئه لها نصيب الاكبر في
الحد من هذه الظاهره اضافه الى اتباع
اساليب جديده داخل الجامعات ترسخ لاسس
وقواعد التعامل بين الشباب والفتيات كريمه
موجوده دائما لكن نستطيع ان نضع للجميع
نظام اجتماعي
موازي في العمليه التعليميه بيعيش في
الطالب هيجتماعيه يعرف الحدود ويعرف
الاصول يعرف العيب ويعرف الخطا وبنعرف
نحاسبه عندما يخطئ ونتنبا بهذا الخطا
مبكرا ومع تعدد الجرائم ووحده المصير يبقى
المجتمع منقسم بين من يبرر للقاتل فعلته
ويلوم الضحيه وبين من يطالب بالقصاص
العادل من المجرم وليبقى العنف ضد النساء
والفتيات اطول جائعه فكا بالعالم بحسب ما
وصفتهم منظمه الامم المتحده